il est comme Harry Potter les Pokémon ou
les billes une star des cours de
récréation bonjour Guillaume Aldebert
bonjour vous parcourez en ce moment la
France en long en large en travers la
tournée d'enfantillage 4 a commencé en
septembre 2001 et 2021 et vous y êtes et
vous y êtes toujours c'est comme s'il
avait convention 2001 en fait quelque
part justement c'est pas lassant d'être
toujours sur la route ou presque non moi
je ne trouve pas je ne trouve pas de
routine en fait dans ce métier là parce
que c'est à chaque fois des villes
différentes des publics différents des
énergies différentes donc c'est même si
on va jouer le même spectacle pendant
deux ans sur 200 représentations c'est
toujours nouveau c'est ça qui est
excitant et puis alors sur la route mais
aussi en avion parce que là vous allez
jouer bien au-delà de nos frontières
ouais déjà avec enfantillages 4 on est
parti en Nouvelle-Calédonie à la Réunion
trois fois et là on part en tournée au
Vietnam on va faire des dates au chimie
on va aussi à Singapour à Hong Kong et
on va faire les Francofolies pour la
première fois à Montréal
les Francos pas à La Rochelle à Montréal
c'est un succès planétaire finalement
c'est chouette quand on peut sortir de
France déjà et puis de se confronter à
des nouveaux publics c'est génial ouais
alors le premier enfant qui gagne il a
15 ans
ça devait être une parenthèse au départ
elle dure la parenthèse oui oui elle se
ferme pas en fait je vais pas je vais
jamais la refermer parce que avec
enfantillages moi j'ai l'impression de
mettre trouver artistiquement vous avez
trouvé votre créneau ouais et votre
public bah oui parce que je suis pas
dans quelque chose d'infantilisant et
qui est fermé refermé sur les enfants
j'ai un public de parents c'est les
parents en fait qui qui emmènent les
enfants à mes concerts c'est drôle et
aujourd'hui on a un public qui est
constitué des trois générations les
enfants les parents et les
grands-parents qui viennent donc des
fois dans les dans les Zénith on a
carrément des des rangs avec la même
famille c'est drôle mais j'adore moi
cette connexion en fait entre ces
générations là alors avant d'être un
chanteur intergénérationnel vous vous
étiez un chanteur pour adulte sur son
française on va dire on a retrouvé une
archive d'en parler public on regarde
dans le rétro c'était en octobre 2000 en
regardant ensemble
Guillaume Aldebert nous sert son plateau
télé sur fond du mour noir le festif
tendance acoustique à le rire jaune
quand les fonctionnaires et autres
manipulateurs du quotidien en prennent
pour leur grade en clair il y a pas que
la télé dans la vie il y a pas que le
poil dans la main
je m'attache surtout à écrire sur les
relations humaines quoi
et mettre jour avec un côté un peu
satirique scénique quoi
[Musique]
vivement la retraite Guillaume Aldebert
bam c'est vraiment une bonne claque
visuel
c'est marrant je me souviens très bien
de cette séance photo on salue
d'ailleurs Michel Buzon le collègue
c'est votre première album ouais fait à
la maison on avait dû en fabriquer 500
et c'est ce qui m'a permis moi de
m'installer de démarcher les premiers
festivals des premières parties aussi
assez vite et ça a démarré avec ça vous
dites vivement la retraite quel regard
vous portez sur ce qui se passe dans la
rue en ce moment
alors j'ai été vraiment j'étais vraiment
dedans mercredi parce que j'étais en
studio à Paris j'ai un petit un petit
appart à Paris qui avait nation et quand
je suis sorti du studio je suis rentré
je suis arrivé place de la Nation et là
c'était la guerre donc moi je me déplace
à Paris en gyrorou vous voyez c'est une
espèce de monocycle électrique ce qui me
permet d'aller très vite d'aller partout
et du coup je devant chez moi il y avait
des CRS qui faisaient des étirements
c'était juste avant que ça ça frite et
tout donc j'ai fait des photos j'ai
suivi un peu le cortège et tout j'étais
derrière le gros ballon CGT et ouais
c'est c'est incroyable en fait de d'être
dans le dans ce dans ce cortège là parce
qu'on est dans le dans ce qui dans
l'histoire de de la France en fait de ce
qui se passe quoi dans la mouvance dans
dans vos chansons vous prenez position
sur des questions de société
l'homoparentalité vous êtes venus avec
un un sweat-shirt exprès mais du coup ça
tombe bien un chanteur ça doit être
engagé pour vous oh je sais pas moi
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai envie
d'endosser j'ai jamais j'ai jamais le
même point voilà
d'accord
je moi je veux surtout pas mettre de la
politique mais j'en mets finalement
parce que je propose une vision du monde
aux enfants et aux parents cette
association par exemple de Sea Shepherd
elle est assez récente il travaille avec
nous en installant des stands dans les
Zénith ils font aussi des ateliers pour
éveiller les enfants à l'écologie à la
faune et à la flore à la défense de tous
ces secteurs là et donc quelque part
forcément il y a un petit peu de
politique qui s'installe on parle d'homo
parentalité on parle de citoyenneté
d'écologie je parle de conditions
animales mais voilà je veux surtout pas
avoir les tickets d'un chanteur engagé
ok
on propose des choix impossibles à nos
invités si je vous dis en solo ou en duo
comme ça plutôt en duo
c'est votre marque de fabrique aussi
vous chanter avec d'autres artistes oui
c'est vrai il y a Thomas dutre dans le
dernier album il y a du tronc Noa enfin
voilà il y en a plein et et qu'est-ce
que ça vous apporte
on a fait une photo où je suis debout au
quotidienne Yannick Noah et je fais
et donc c'est là ça va je suis plus
grand que lui mais c'est parce qu'il est
assis oui des duos moi j'ai toujours
invité des acteurs des chanteurs sur les
dans les titres pour pour qu'ils
puissent jouer des personnages
et je trouve ça rend les choses sont
plus riches et plus vivantes et vous
avez un complice sur scène qui est pas
n'importe qui c'est Charlie vous chantez
avec votre fils qu'est-ce que ça vous
apporte ça bah beaucoup d'émotions pour
lui aussi je pense parce que c'est drôle
parce que Charlie il a commencé à la fin
d'enfantillage 3 où on démarrait les
Zéniths donc il a démarré ses premières
scènes ça a été tout de suite des scènes
de 5 6000 donc c'est chaud il avait 7
ans à l'époque et il pas démonter quoi
et pour moi c'était c'est moi qui avait
peur en fait c'est pas lui en parlant de
peur vous exposez vos enfants sur les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'est une
question que vous êtes posé il y a des
parents qui le font pas vous vous
l'assumez ben je l'assume faut que eux
l'assument et envie de le faire quoi
donc je réexplique ce qui se passe quand
on monte des petits sketchs on va faire
des stories des trucs sur les réseaux
comme on fait de temps en temps je leur
explique que plein de gens vont le voir
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez envie de
ça s'ils ont pas envie ils le font pas
il y a plein de choses que je leur
propose qui n'ont pas envie de faire des
enregistrements des vidéos donc voilà
moi je vais jamais les pousser sur scène
je veux vraiment qu'ils aient envie et
qui et qu'ils aient conscience de ce qui
se passe en fait une dernière question
Guillaume Aldebert Brassens ou Metallica
ah c'est dur ça je peux pas influences
que vous revendiquez tout le temps bah
oui parce que ça fait partie de mon
enfance et de mon adolescence Brassens
c'est vraiment la fondation et ben alors
tu adores faut vraiment les fondations
de ce que j'écoutais chez mes parents
donc voilà c'est cette voix et puis à
l'adolescence à l'adolescence Metallica
parce que parce que je me suis construit
aussi musicalement avec tous ces
personnages qui sont dans dans il y a
des passerelles on peut révéler oui
il y aura du métal ce sera une
inspiration mais vous alliez dire il y
aura Metallica je sais pas peut-être ce
serait dans mes fantasmes mais oui on va
on va faire un pas de côté on va faire
un enfantillages rock'n'roll qui va
s'appeler enfantillages 666 merci
beaucoup Guillaume Aldebert je précise
vous allez jouer en Asie au Canada mais
pour vos femmes francontois vous serez à
Audincourt au festival
[Musique]
mince rencontrer racine voilà des
racines à Audincourt au mois de juin
merci beaucoup